hello and welcome
everyone to the active inference live
stream it is active inference live
stream
11.1 on one two two two
2 0 2 0 december 22nd 2020.
this is going to be a really fun
discussion and hopefully
we'll see if anyone else joins us but
other than that we've got a nice small
group
and i'm really looking forward to
talking to you all about this paper
welcome to the active inference lab
everyone the active inference lab is an
experiment in online team communication
learning and practice related to active
inference you can find us
at our website activeinference.org on
twitter
at email our youtube channel or our
public key based team and username
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and as far as video
etiquette for live streams
mute if there's noise in your background
raise your hands so that we can hear
from everybody who wants to speak
and we'll use respectful speech behavior
etc so just a couple
points of process today on december 22nd
we are in
11.1 and next week will be the last act
imp stream for 2020 on december 29th
2020 and that will be at 7 30 to 9 a.m
pst on the same paper that we're talking
about today and everyone is welcome to
join
then we are very happy to announce the
active inference stream
schedule for 2021 which can be found at
this
rb.gui link going to this link you'll be
able to find out
which papers we'll be discussing which
week and how to participate if you are
so
interested and also all these sessions
come and join for
however much you can so if you have to
join late or leave early it's all good
we just want to
have participation and your perspective
this is what the calendar looks like so
looking ahead to some of the first
papers we're going to discuss
the first weeks of january we're going
to be discussing
um in 13 a paper by adam safron and
colin de young
in the second weeks of january we're
going to be talking about mel andrews
paper the math is not the territory so
everybody should be
finding exciting papers and letting us
know when we can read them for active
stream
also just one last note if you go to
activeinference.org
you'll see a call for a collaboration
for the active inference lab 2021
so check that out if you'd like to get
involved in any way
okay thanks for all that here we are in
active inference stream 11.1
and today first we are going to have
introductions and warm-up questions
and then we're going to turn to the
sections of 11.1
the paper we're discussing is
sophisticated affective inference
simulating anticipatory affective
dynamics of imagining future events by
casper hesp
at all in 2020 from the iy proceedings
we're going to talk about the aims and
claims the abstract and the roadmap
and then we'll go through the figures
and maybe even some of the citations
that are referenced in the paper
next week we're going to be discussing
the same paper so
save and submit your questions and get
in touch if you'd like to participate
okay here we are in the intros and
warm-ups
so let's introduce ourselves we can each
give a short introduction or check-in
and then pass to somebody
who hasn't spoken so i'm daniel i'm in
california
and i'll pass it to sasha
hi i'm sasha i'm also in california
and i will pass it to blue
hi i'm blue i'm based out of new mexico
i'm an independent research
consultant looking at
bioinformatics a lot and a lot of
asian-based modeling mostly
and i'll pass it to stephen hello i'm
stephen i'm based in
canada in toronto and i'm interested in
the ways active inference can help
inform
the ways groups and communities
understand their place in the world
and i will pass it over to
ivan let's go to alex actually
oh sorry yeah hello
my name is alex i am in moscow russia
i'm a researcher in systems management
school
and i'm trying to find interconnections
and possible ways
to connect active inference with
systems engineering and system thinking
frameworks
awesome and have uh we have new fellow
gitzer
it could be ryan so any time that ryan
or anyone
joins we'll just hop in and go from
there
um okay i just want to check these
messages all right
thanks okay let's go to the warm-up
questions
so for the warm-up questions we can each
just raise our hand give some thoughts
and we'll have plenty of time in today's
relatively small
discussion to get through everyone's
thoughts on the paper and on the
associated areas
so first just an introductory question
is
what gets you excited to read and
discuss this paper
so thanks everyone for showing up and
for those who are listening live and in
replay
and i'll tie that to the second question
as well how can we learn
and communicate the technical aspects of
active inference in an accessible
fashion so it's kind of like intention
setting
as we head into this relatively
technical paper
and indeed relatively technical area of
active
inference that draws on mathematics and
computer science
and a few other areas so again anyone
can raise their hand but i'll give a
first answer
just think about what's something that
gets you excited uh in terms of the
content
and then from a process-based
perspective what is a way that we can
learn and communicate
excessively so what um let's go with
steven first
well i this is interesting because i
think
this discussion came up on one of our
conversations on our chats i think
finding different ways in um
will give you different ways to
communicate to the
different people that you're talking to
so i think active inference
needs to be connected to some process
that people are familiar with
in terms of how they make meaning in the
world otherwise it's a big big
jump to build it all from first
principles
yes so definitely it's exciting to hear
about things that we've heard about in a
new
perspective so i agree when we see
keywords in an active inference paper
and we know that it's going to be like
familiar territory but approach from a
different angle that's exciting
any other thoughts there
alex
yeah thanks for me it was interesting
how it provided an example and
the case for defining
agent and generative model
for this agent and so as a result to
have
a simulation as possible ways
way to
in a practical way when we usually
discuss on papers here is
like exact case for simulation
thanks okay blue
so i think a lot of things were exciting
to me but like computational
psychiatry that's a field like what is
that about
um but i mean it really just kind of
hones in on
like maybe are we like a sum of input
output
like is our effective state like just
the direct results of our input
and if so like i don't know that it
feels a little bit like
brave new world-ish like are we gonna
move toward
you know control theory and optimization
of that
affective state it's kind of um just
like crazy and
a little bit scary to me yep from
implicitly
to explicitly steering others behavior
and valence and affect
sasha um yeah i just remember this
readings paper when it uh came out
earlier this year and thinking
like what does affect have to do
with uh agents and and why is that
important to model
or to include um mathematically
and so that's been something i'm
still thinking about um and um
yeah very interested in the aspects of
computational psychiatry and yet
i guess just on a deeper level reminds
us that um
affect and mood are really important
aspects of the human experience and not
something to be
um ignored uh in favor of like
bigger decision aspects that it really
does matter
yeah one thought on that is that in
active inference
we're always talking about how
everything is prediction
and then we're always talking about how
prediction isn't just a point estimate
of what will happen
it's actually a state estimate and an
uncertainty about that estimate
so you know i predict the giants are
going to win the world series and i'm
this
certain about it or i'm not certain
about it so it's always the state
estimation
and the uncertainty and so that
uncertainty is the risk or the ambiguity
depending on the context
and then the state itself good versus
bad is the valence
and so it's sort of like the affect
which is multi-dimensional contains
something about how good or bad it is
and then orthogonally or independently
whether it's good or bad
is whether you're confident or not and
so you could be very confident
about being happy or very confident
about being sad
ryan we see you joining can you hear us
not sure while ryan is figuring out
his setup but thanks sasha for bringing
up the computational psychiatry angle
and
i hope that ryan will be able to fill us
in soon stephen
yeah i think this is a really important
point because
when we think about how things happen
over time
in this process how that gets integrated
how we make sense
not just in some sort of snapshot about
a situation i.e
we think this is a problem situation
and then suddenly there's this emotional
churn
that's somehow a byproduct of that but
actually
it's not a snapshot this ongoing process
which seems
incredibly impossibly complex
is made all of it's made sense of
because of affect
and emotion it's not some freudian
sort of repression that's sitting there
in the background as a as a mistake but
it's actually like
the big game in town which is pretty
revolutionary really
interesting and also uh yet another
transformation or sort of paradigm shift
associated with
thinking from a free energy perspective
is rather than prioritizing the valence
the plus versus minus and then having
risk or ambiguity as a secondary layer
we can actually think about the
ambiguity reduction as the primary drive
and then the plus and minus as falling
out of the quest to reduce uncertainty
rather than uncertainty being an
auxiliary factor
in the quest to improve outcomes so it
just shows how there's these two
related dimensions of prediction which
is the state
and the uncertainty and then we can
think about how
prioritizing one or the other is going
to lead to different outcomes ryan we
can see you raise your hand can you
talk
okay how about you can raise your hand
and lower it in morse code and we'll
communicate with you that way
but ryan thanks for trying and if it's
not working with your current browser
setup for whatever
reason today then we'll make sure to
work it out with you in the interim and
for next week and for following
discussions we'll
have you on unabated all right and
here's our
last warm-up question which is something
that you are wondering about or would
like to have resolved
by the end of today's discussion
blue so i don't really expect this to be
resolved but i wonder instead of um
modeling you know to predict like
positive or negative
valence like if there is a way to
model um like equanimity in this
in this sense like so neutral valence
like is that
um i mean what what would drive that
force and so i'm just kind of wondering
as we
dive deeper into the model if that's
going to become clear or not
can you um explain what you mean by that
and what other types of models might
exist to think about that
um so just like how
you know the results here were geared
obviously toward um you know pushing
assets towards either a positive state
or
driving away from a negative state i
mean that's i assume the idea
so what about driving toward
a neutral state like is is this
something that's been
considered right like so you know
overthinking tends to lead like
overthinking like
supposing about the future leads to
like you know these supposed negative
thoughts that and so then it's anxiety
producing because you're worried about
these negative thoughts like so that's
overthinking or thinking like worst case
scenario perhaps right so people do like
a lot of thought redirection
in this cognitive behavioral therapy
like people do thought redirection so
that maybe you're thinking
in not such a negative state but but in
a more positive way like well it could
also be great right like so
there's that but what about like the
non-thinking
so if you non-think could you lead to
like a valence neutral
like valence equals zero to
just have this kind of equanimity
baseline that's like
something maybe meditation meditation
achieves right so like can you can you
work towards like non-think maybe
non-thinking is that that valence
neutral
right like so i don't know how um
how can that factor into computational
psychiatry and it has that been thought
of before i don't know
cool great question and so it's kind of
like if we were going to be doing
modeling of a car there's probably a lot
of different
ways that you could set up car crashes
or cars that drive off the rails
and we just want to know about what does
it look like to have a computational
psychiatry model that isn't just
capturing a negative spiral
as overthinking progressively sort of
accelerates but rather something that
returns to the neutral
attractor state or something that's
related to mindfulness or attention to
detail
or abstraction but not hyper abstraction
rumination but not hyper rumination
so could the strange attractor be a
neutral or even a healthy one
not a delusionally positive or negative
stephen i suppose you could say that
like
there's thousands and thousands of
dimensions which are kind of sitting
there as neutral
and you really notice it when you you're
not there and you've got to re-establish
it so that's what they talk about
incense making is
when you're immersed in something you
don't do sense making but once you
suddenly jolts you out of it certain
consciously
you might be doing unconscious sense
making but more conscious level
is when you're surprised basically when
things aren't
going the way that your habitual
understanding of them are
and then suddenly your cognition's got
to kick in and say okay how do i
work out what is the sense of what i
should be doing at the moment
and that's when everything becomes
transparent so it's
it's quite interesting to actually then
see this now
that the again taking that that thinking
and
and that sort of abstract and bringing
it right into the body
and the and and the emotions as the kind
of like the way of really knowing
i mean in some ways is your mind
checking in with your body
was your body checking in with your mind
cool very interesting about the mind and
the body and always an important
take um any other thoughts here or can
we
continue sasha
um yeah another aspect of this paper i
really liked
is discussing the um like future
clinical applications of
understanding the mechanism of how
certain existing therapies work because
there's
a lot of different kinds of therapies
out there
um and namely i'm thinking of like art
therapy
and but of course
all other forms included um to
understand to start to understand why
they work
and by what mechanism um they
might be tapping into uh
this kind of affective and predictive
coding so i think that's really exciting
and
i also wonder who is fit to address
those kinds of questions
is it medical professionals is it
psychologists um who is best suited for
that role
because um it's a very you know uh
challenging subject to talk about
without um
giving people perhaps uh incorrect
medical advice or
false hope and so that that's just
something
that um i'm curious about but i
don't want to step on any toes
cool let's keep that in mind and
as ryan joins and rejoins but no need to
send the jitsi
messages because we can hear it very
loudly so let's just
hope that ryan can figure it out
otherwise we'll take care of it for next
week
cool here we are in the paper for today
which is sophisticated affective
inference
simulating anticipatory affective
dynamics
of imagining future events and this was
from october 2020
in the first international workshop on
active inference or iy
and i believe that more recently like in
the last couple of days this has been
codified into a book so we're using the
researchgate version
the aims and the claims of the paper
were a bit rehearsed in
11.0 so go and check that one out if you
want a deeper dive into what the aims
and the claims were
but the big point of this paper was to
take two
bodies of previous work which was the
sophisticated inference which is
sophisticated meaning deep
through time and then affective
inference
affect being related to emotion and
valence and
fusing these two threads into
sophisticated
affective inference so deep through time
and
also involving affect and the big
question
from a non-active inference jargon
perspective is how to model
affective and anticipatory agents of
course we're going to be thinking about
that within the active inference
framework
and then we're going to be asking what
features do these simulated agents
display
and then how does this carry out or
connect to
areas that are like psychiatry or
cybernetics control theory
all these fun things that we've been
talking about in previous active streams
how are we going to connect what we're
learning about today something that's a
recent development in only the last
couple of months
this is the current developments so
let's have fun
let's um treat it as just an initial
inroad
and a connection between these two
different areas
here's the abstract and again it was
read through in 11.0
and we're gonna just go more discussion
oriented
in the panels that we have but
fundamentally in the abstract they
describe
what i just said that they combine those
two
different types of active inference
models sophisticated and deep parametric
models
and then they use a augmented markov
decision process
please know jitsi chat if possible thank
you ryan
we'll see you soon um and uh
then they give a minimal simulation at
the end
of a ruminating agent and that is where
blue was talking about the
negative agent that sort of spirals off
into negative affect
okay um the road map of the paper
there's not that many stops not that
many gas stations along the way
it's also a short paper and i have it in
this other tab if we want to
go through it as it is as a paper
because it's so clear and concise
but what they do is introduce the ideas
then
show a couple figures that just
summarize the model
and show a table with what the uh
formalisms were
at this point does anyone have any
thoughts or
where do we want to go like what was
something that somebody thought
structurally or from a topical
perspective that they wanted to bring up
or it's okay if not
all right let's uh look at the figures
and then use the figures
as our scaffold for kind of
understanding what they are up to in
this paper
and then understand why they did some of
the things that they did
and then what some of the next steps
could be so
here we are in figure one and figure one
does anyone wanna
point something out that they see first
so feel free to just raise your hand any
time um
in figure one i've put red boxes
around two pieces these are the two
pillars that things are being built upon
here is the affect of inference part
which we'll get to in a second and then
in the middle
is the task specific sophisticated
inference so that's deep inference here
and then as with a few other figures
we've seen time
is moving from left to right now
in this model there are several boxes
that are shaded
and that's because there's this
recursive embedding of the models
so we start with one single time point
that's this
up here on the top level of the model
this is like the outer layer of the
model it's kind of like the hour hand of
the model
you can think of and what's happening at
each
time point of the model itself is that
the agent
is doing a forecast through time so it's
kind of like
in the year 2000 you're doing a forecast
for the next hundred years
and then it's a recursive string because
at 2000 you do in 100 year prediction
and then 2001
you do 100 year prediction so it's like
at each time point each big hour tick of
the big model
we're going to be doing this recursive
uh
rolling out of predictions through time
so
that's the biggest structure of the
model it's top level
is the actual time that's the real
what's happening in the world we can
think
but then the agent is involved in this
recursive
anticipatory simulation and that's the
deep
or the sophisticated inference now
there's a few other elements to
highlight and again anyone can
raise their hand at any time the first
thing
is that within this prediction through
time
we've seen a couple elements here we've
seen s the states
a how the hidden state estimates are
mapped to observations
we've also seen b which is how the
states change through time or are
predicted to change their time again
this is like happening within an
instance of the agent
we've also seen you which is how actions
how policy maps on to the way that
states change
remember that policy enters the b matrix
so states are being inferred and then
we're inferring the b matrix which is
basically how our policies
affect how states influence uh how
states change through time
another notable feature here and
slightly outside of the blue box but in
the gray box is this gamma
or a precision parameter so as we do
this roll out
at a given instant and think ahead
through time how things are going to be
we're not just estimating the state
rollout through time
we're also estimating our actions
through time and how that influences
states and how they change
and a layer above that is this gamma
which is how sure am i about that
that's this layer of precision in the
estimate and that's coming through this
g
which is um related to the estimated
free energy
so again for each moment of the rollout
the agent is estimating a bunch of
things
inside this model and then stephen i'll
get to you after i finish this last
little bit
and then in the moment in the actual
timeline of the agent
it is having affect and so these
are the ways that these two models are
combined and we can look at some more
um unpackings in other slides but i just
want to start with the actual figure
used in the paper itself before going to
another citation
and the sophisticated inference is
capturing this deep roll out at an
instant
with a precision estimator and the
affective inference
is capturing this affective state that
carries forward in time
and so combining affective and
sophisticated inference
is quite literally structurally
combining
the patterns of affective inference from
this hesp at all citation
with the topological model structures of
sophisticated inference
we'll stay on here and continue thinking
about it stephen
so would i be right in saying that the
the
effective inference over time
is is kind of looking at the shape of
how
actions look like they're going to turn
out over time and
and sort of putting a feeling to that
in a simplistic term it's like there's
it's not
so you've got all these fairly discreet
moments being
looked at or assessed over time and the
sort of the shape
of that is what the feeling
is about that makes sense it's like is
it going is
is it like am i predicting this to be a
roller coaster ride
of uncertainty over the next few minutes
or am i
expecting it to be smooth you know
because that would be the kind of
the shape of the observations and the
expectations
as i stretch it out over time and that
itself becomes
something which is obs you know has a
generative model
um tracking it would that be a one way
of saying it
great and thanks for phrasing it in the
wording like as
it appears to you so let's start with
that shape
of the prediction that shape is actually
the shape of a probability distribution
it's the shape of the probability
distribution that is a generative model
and the shape of that it's kind of like
a cloud of points
or the bubble that encloses the cloud of
points it's a shape
that is existing let's just think
initially in two dimensions so like a
piece of paper
and on the y-axis is going to be how
rewarding is it
lots of reward or negative reward and
then the x-axis is precision
from low precision to high precision and
so
you could imagine that the shape could
be all the way clustered up on the top
right corner
so that would be high expected reward
but high precision that's the best state
the lowest state would be like the
bottom left where it's like low expected
reward
and low precision so again the reward
prioritizing mindset says the agent's
state should correspond to their state
estimate
the active inference perspective says no
no the agent's affect
is going to be related to their
uncertainty estimate more so
because if you have a small positive
state estimate
but you're very precise i'm gonna give
you five dollars plus or minus one cent
you say great and if you say i'm going
to give you five dollars plus or minus
you say wait a minute you're gonna maybe
take twenty dollars for me
even if it's a very small chance that
isn't as good as getting five
plus or minus one and so this is where
the state estimate
and the precision estimator are
orthogonal and so that's what delineates
the shape of the distribution that is
the generative model of the future
now in a traditional computational
psychology model
again agent affect would be tracked by
the
state estimate if it's above zero
expected then you're good
if it's below zero it's bad whereas in
the active inference framework
good affect is going to be associated
with precise estimates
and anxiety negative affect is going to
be associated with
high uncertainty and so as this agent
runs simulations going forward and
rolling them out we can look at what
that looks like
even if the expected reward is positive
if the ambiguity is high the uncertainty
is high it can
be anxiety producing so that is what
we're really
tracking is there's the structure of
this model which is like the topology or
the connectedness of how different
variables
influence each other in the model but
then the outcome of
all of this is the shape of the
distribution
of the prediction of the agent and
that's respectively just like all
predictions are
about state as well as uncertainty so
estimate about the world states the
hidden states in the world
and then a metacognitive estimate of our
precision
and so it's like this is one click
through time and then
the agent acts but it's simulating its
future actions at this moment
and then the actual model clicks over
and then it's in the next time step
for the agent and it starts simulating
from that moment
going forward and so that's one of the
features
that is uh something that's a hallmark
of this model
is it's like the game that's being
played has a net
positive return and let's just assume
that we had a degree of agency
we could probably choose small winning
outcomes within this game that we're
about to show
however by spiraling and by ruminating
deep through time
the agent starts thinking about
potential roads that are highly
uh rewarding as well as a small fraction
of paths that are very negative
and then the uncertainty in that
distribution
the spread on the x-axis or the higher
uncertainty on the x-axis
is actually leading to it being anxiety
producing even if the state estimate is
positive stephen
yeah i think this is this supports some
of the challenges we also
find with you know if you you see this
the numbers for the stock market you can
get this sense of full sense of
certainty that we all know what's going
on and it gives us
for some people that can make them quite
relaxed
and confident and here i go you know um
bullish as we might say and this this
would sort of support that sense of like
um if you're given this high level of
supposedly precision
and supposed um accuracy and
reliability you could get a full sense
of of that
and and that could be where you know at
the same time people challenge that and
look at like we need to blow that apart
because
you know if you if the confidence in
that suddenly disappears
and you see it as not being as precise
as you thought
the anxiety rises greatly and
you know other ways of thinking might
need to be thought you know come into
play cool
good connection there with decision
making in markets
which are very related to not just
estimates of value but estimates of
volatility
and uncertainty estimates about value
and about volatility
and so then you have people trading vix
you know trading the volatility index
or leveraging that and so these are like
higher level
ambiguity about ambiguity or risk about
risk
and then all of that is associated with
valence is it a good trade or a bad
trade
and so that's like coming back to
sasha's question about valence and
affect it's sort of like well there's so
many layers and ways that you could
leverage
trading but then in the end it's like
right but am i going to do
action a or not is it going to be a or b
is it a good trade
or not and that implicitly entails
preferences like i want to see my number
of bitcoin go up
not down but if you didn't have that
preference which is part of the c
matrix which is not shown here it's part
of the g if you didn't have a preference
then you wouldn't know which policy to
partake in like if you don't know where
you're going
every step is a losing step but then
with a preference vector c
you can actually ask is this trade a
good one or a bad one
and that is not just is the expected
value above zero
again that's reward landia that's reward
first uncertainty as a satellite
we're taking uncertainty first and we
still want to partake
in preferences in preference guided
policy selection
so instead of doing preferences to
reward maximization and then we'll deal
with the uncertainty later
it's like let's go from preference to
policy selection
with ambiguity as the heart of what
we're doing
and reward will fall out as a function
of reducing uncertainty about optimal
action in the world
given our preferences and affordances so
this is sort of the simple
uh rearranging of ideas and
reconfiguring that leads to some of
these innovative insights in active
inference
steven just adding something
into that is it also shows it can work
the other way
i know someone who does trading and he
has to sort of
monitor his heart rate they do a whole
thing where he does like some relaxing
and measures the heart rate and that
before doing the work
so that the state of the body doesn't
mask what's actually going on you know
so
this also shows that you know if your
physical state
and your you know emotional state is is
is out of whack in any
way your your ability to to do this deep
inference might be
skewed or even you know uh
lost because the the top level in the
diagram
is not necessarily tapping into the real
data
it's just tapping into the the the
values
about context arousal valence etc that
is just in the whole system for the
person correct and there's a lot of
behavioral
research not done in the active
inference framework that shows like when
people are in a pessimistic framework
they might be more willing to satisfy
with like a smaller
gain in the short term whereas when
somebody's feeling like
abundant or optimistic or confident
about their success
they might be able to delay
gratification and
partake in larger gains in the future
and so if you have somebody who's
carrying over
from the other tab quite literally
negative affect
or adversarial affect about the world
and they flip over their trading account
they're going to be making different
kinds of decisions based upon their
affective state
that's going to carry into their
estimates of precision
which is related to anxiety higher
precision
lower anxiety those two are negatively
correlated
and then again in this caption the um
imagined action model precision actions
and states and outcomes
everything inside of the gray and the
blue box is
inside the mind of an agent at a moment
and so this is the rollout inside of the
mind of an agent
at a moment let's look at figure 2 and
talk about this game
that they actually simulate out so this
is four state game um it's uh
there's a lot of games that you could
simulate but this is just one game
and each of the edges reflect
transitions that are possible
so you start on like square one and then
you can either move to square two or
square three with some probability
and you start out with a gain of zero
it's a neutral state you can go to a
safe small game
so if you're just wanting to play it
safe you could hang out and go between
one and two
however also you can go to this high
gain
three now three you're getting twice as
much
money however there's a one in three
chance
that you're going to or depending on how
these edges are parameterized i should
say there's a chance that you can move
into this
absorbing state that's painful and so
the two adjectives there are painful
so it has a negative reward of negative
two
and it's absorbing because you see that
it can also uh
swallow your trajectory like once you
end up in four
it's sort of like a negative state and
so there are absorbing states in the
world
like death let's say once you hit
this state you're staying in that state
and so the agent is starting here
and so it's like which square should i
walk on to get um
you know the most money or something
like that and so if it just walks around
it's going to end up here really quickly
and get into this painful absorbing
state and so it's thinking okay there's
some paths i can imagine
where i just walk back and forth between
one and two there's some other paths
where i walk around
on one two three i'm just getting money
or neutral every step
and so what it's doing here is time one
it's saying well on my next move i could
go to one two or three
and i could go to four but actually this
edge isn't there so it's like not likely
so
the first step it's like it's literally
all good your expectation is
either one or two so your kind of
estimate is a mean
of one and a half with a small variance
okay but now here if you stay on one and
then continue on one now you're getting
this
path at time point three would give you
zero here you'd have one dollar total
zero zero one here you'd have three
dollars total here you'd have
plus one zero so one two four
here you'd have two plus two is four so
you're getting all these estimates now
you have some fours
but you also have some two negative twos
and some uh
negative fours so as you're rolling out
this simulation
at each time point actually the
expectation is getting higher
because if you think about it you can
get negative two or plus two that
cancels out and then plus one
so each game you play each step the
expectation is going to strictly grow
however the variance is also going to
strictly grow
and so this is related to a few other
probability games
where it's like will you play this game
where we gamble
and then it's like double or nothing uh
following double or nothing it's like
the saint peter's
st petersburg uh gamble it has another
name as well
and the reason why people don't pay
infinite money
to pay these uh to play these games with
an infinite expected value
is because the variance is so high and
so what's happening is as the agent is
rolling out in its minds
these possible trajectories and this
could be like chess trajectories or it
could be like action selection policies
or trades
as it's rolling these out the variance
is increasing
and so that's making it anxious um
that's sort of the heart of what's
happening
and then as we trace out the time steps
of the model
this is again just one trace of the
simulation they're not exploring every
parameter but this is very illustrative
what happens is that in the first couple
of hundred
time points of the model the valence
is good the agent is feeling good it's
feeling good about ending up
in large reward states and it has a
fairly precise
model on action and a small fraction of
an
of the imagined events are negative 0.04
but then what starts happening is
because that negative state is absorbing
you get more and more trajectories
lining up on this right side
where it's like 4 as an absorbing state
and so
that is making that uh making the
uncertainty strictly rise so around 500
we have this phase transition
where the precision on the agent's
estimate
drops rapidly it's like yeah i'm not
sure what's going to happen after 500
time points because there's some paths
that are just super bad and there's some
that are super good
so when it was one time point i was like
pretty sure i was gonna get one dollar
or two dollars and i felt great
but now that you're asking me to predict
500 time points out
i don't know if i'm gonna have a hundred
thousand dollars or be a hundred
thousand dollars
in debt and that's actually getting me
anxious that i don't know
the precision and so again if someone
said hey don't worry about the future
because the expected value is gonna be
positive a thousand dollars
that's not a thousand dollars in my
pocket that's a precise thousand dollars
if somebody says the expected value is a
thousand dollars but it has a huge
variance it's going to be anxiety
producing
and so even though the threat perception
is inching up
from 0.04 to 0.1 so it still is not more
than a 10 percent
uh barely chance of these highly
threatening events happening
it turns out that um the
uncertainty is what drives the valence
not the percentage of negative events
and then also interestingly and this can
be overreading into one trace of the
model
but the phase transition the precision
and uh valence happen at exactly the
same time
around 500 right before 500.
interestingly
the threat perception is going down
overall
leading up to 500 and then it starts
kicking up again
that's sort of like okay i drank all the
coffee i'm feeling great it's like
oh no i'm starting to get a little tired
that coffee is not going to work that
quantitative easing is not going to work
and so even though the threat perception
actually isn't as high as it has been
the precision being so low leads to the
valence being negative
because the valence is being derived
again from the anxiety from the
uncertainty
not from the expected value this is like
a point we can always return to
because it's a great example of the
complementarity of traditional
reward-centric understandings of reward
learning and this more precision guided
understanding of action selection in the
niche
okay any thoughts on those figures
that's sort of the contribution of the
paper in
many ways is just to make this
combination model
that features the affective inference of
the agent
in their timeline and then at each
moment this
imagined rollout and um yeah
it's a discrete time model
and uh yeah any thoughts or questions or
there's more stuff we can continue to
look
through
cool so just to put it up there and
anyone can raise their hand
table one has some of the mathematical
details
so hopefully with ryan and any other
authors next week we'll be able to talk
about these details and uh
here is that that gamma which is
one over the precision so sometimes
you'll hear about it as
precision maximizing other times you'll
hear about it as uncertainty
minimizing and those two the min and the
max
are related by this one over feature
just
one point so it's kind of like um on
network
networks there's one type of problem
called
the max flow like you want to have flow
through network
internet or water or resources and so
you might want to know
what the cut is that's going to be most
damaging or the least damaging to the
network
and so sometimes the most and the least
are related by this one over
feature um okay any thoughts because
there's a lot of formalisms we can
continue to
walk through and we have a good amount
of time but like
maybe just pausing here what would be
something
you would say to somebody who had never
heard of active inference
and just what is something that it
captures that other
models haven't captured or something
that you'd be excited to see it head in
the direction towards stephen thanks
well i think the counterintuitive nature
and the ability for things
to be unexpectedly stable and
unexpectedly
transitioned is something that
i don't know of in a way that
traditional models of the world
would show you you know because you know
you could be like oh
people would normally either just take
one of those moments and then that gets
extrapolated for everything but actually
you need to follow it over time
because it matters a lot
it does and it needs to be um kind of
through time in two ways the actual
agent
needs to be progressing through time but
at each time point the agent needs to be
simulating
time points of the past present and
future and so that's this like double
timeline that's happening with the
model's topology here
is you could have another pink box right
next to this one
and that would be like the next time
point of the agent but it's like right
now it's 10 a.m and i'm looking ahead to
10 11 12 and then it's 11 and then i'm
thinking ahead again but i'm also
looking back
and all of that is being spun out of the
generative model
of the trajectory stephen yeah that's
and i thought it was interesting i
haven't seen a positive
valence and a negative value i haven't
seen sort of two dynamics
mapped alongside each other
simultaneously normally there's just the
one so i thought that's something
that's kind of uh the good and bad as
to you know it's not just about good
it's about the blending of good and bad
i thought that's good so
i mean theoretically you could have
loads of variants of that
you know you could have good the bad the
ugly
yep yep valence just like uh an electron
or a proton you know valence
of plus or minus that's plus to minus
positive and negative valence
but affect is a multi-dimensional
landscape
and so that is something that could be
explored in a higher dimensional way
but again let's think about that trading
example
there's so many ways oh it's an elegant
trade it's an ugly trade it was a clumsy
one
it was a uh one with very much foresight
or it was a retributive trade all these
adjectives
but then what does it boil down to given
my preferences and my affordances was it
a good trade
and that if your preferences are hey i
have too much money
i'm trying to sponsor a couple people
who have less crypto than me
than a quote good trade given that
preference
vector might not look like a preference
uh
or a policy selected by somebody with a
different preference
so that is where agent-specific
preferences come into play
is you're never going to get away from
that the agent is not doing this neutral
calculation
followed by a secondary step of policy
selection
the preferences for policy and for
outcomes are entrenched
within the kernel of this model at every
single time step stephen
and and that gives a plausible bayesian
route to your gut feeling
i mean some of those emotions like
you're saying
the an elegant trade might be kind of a
cognitive process and
some other type of part of it might be
kicking your deep
you know there's certain times when
you're thinking about stuff and then
suddenly you get a sinking feeling in
your stomach
you know and it's like well that that um
who knows where that's coming from but
this gives a
you only get one overall
sort of gut feeling you only get one
overall sort of
um move to actively infer
how to take action in the world and all
these
different things they only become
available to you when you maybe reflect
on it later and you have to describe
why you had that gut feeling like you
just mentioned
there could be hundreds of different
things all being basically
integrated exactly and that's this go
no go hey i'm just not feeling good
about this this whole vacation
or i'm just feeling really great i don't
know what's behind the door number four
but i'm feeling great about it
that valence aspect of prediction for
the future
is like the highest level control
summary statistic
it's like are we going to accept this
person into the college
or not there's so many other dimensions
but it gets distilled
into the choke point through the mark
called blanket of action
it gets distilled into go or no go
on that specific person or that specific
policy or that specific outcome
and so that's actually the justification
for the use of valence
as a simple positive to negative even
though there's so many other dimensions
to affect
overall it does get distilled into this
gut feeling
which you can go into and and uh you can
cognize you can add
adjectives on top but it's sort of
interesting it's like
is the gut feeling just positive versus
negative
and when you introspect do you get
higher and higher levels of abstracted
polysyllabic emotions or do you get
deeper and deeper into your body and
into increasingly
summary statistics like go no go um
freeze fight these are things like go
and no go
let's look through a couple oh sasha go
ahead
that's kind of what i was thinking is
with this model
of valence would uh
a human participant let's say um be able
to
self-report in this similar way about
their valence during an experience or is
this kind of like the
you know hidden by the markov blanket
and um
we can have these models to help explain
what was happening at the time but
those states might be unaccessible to uh
people actually experiencing
this you know decision making process
and um yeah it just reminds me of
i guess how people spend money and
thinking about
economic um economic decisions that
people make that are you know either
logical or not logical
and that it really um has little to do
with
the money that we have
and then the mindset that we have about
the money and like how we ought to be
spending it
and um you know who we want to be
supporting or not with our
uh investment decision and
yeah it's just really uh i don't know
it's at such a higher level
than just thinking about someone's
salary
it's how they interact with the economic
system
and um what role they might play in it
and just especially in the holidays like
all i can think is we're
so deeply influenced by um
times and like season and tradition
with how we choose to uh how and where
we choose to spend money
right you send money you literally give
money away to people on their birthday
on their biorhythm or you know in the
holiday season
and then also what you just said sasha
reminded me of like coarse graining
estimates
and why it's so important if your
economic estimate that you're making is
will we have enough or not you might be
very confident that you'll have enough
say i don't know the details but
i'm confident that we'll have enough or
even
i'm confident we're not going to have
enough and we're going to have to do xyz
policy
okay we can work with that but if you're
trying to do a estimate down to the cent
you might have a very noisy estimate and
then
apparently people can get quite anxious
about
relatively small amounts of money that
are way up there
in the big salary range is it going to
be this number
or a slightly higher or slightly smaller
number
so there's this jockeying and
uncertainty up there at the high level
because they're doing a nine figure
precision estimate with a large variance
whereas there's something to be said for
coarse graining and simplifying
and functionalizing it and actually not
just reducing the cognitive load
but increasing the precision of our
estimate even if the state estimate
is inferior so there's so much there to
continue
exploring let's just walk through some
more of these formalisms because
most of this paper um we can just scroll
through it just to
you know show you but it's 10 pages long
including references
and basically they introduce
give that figure one that we just looked
at give figure two that we just looked
at
give the table we looked at show the
results
for figure three and there's the whole
paper so short
very very short so let's go into these
two citations
underlying the paper centrally and then
just find out what they
might show us and we're going to be
talking about
deeply felt affect in april i believe so
again sophisticated
affective inference is drawing the
affect from this left side and the
temporal depth from the right side
three areas we could imagine this area
of research heading towards would be
more advanced simulations
so agents that are simulating in
continuous time
or with higher dimensional action
policies just like we've seen from
active 8
with scaling active inference or towards
the computational psychiatry angle
something that ryan smith and others
have written review papers
about and a lot of empirical work as
well so we'll hear more about that next
time
and then there's this angle of the
models for robotics which is like
what if the drone had a top level
summary statistic
that's just like is this mission going
well or not
and if not then that might engage some
um
policies like head back home or pause or
land or get to safety
but that's a top level summary statistic
that even robots might be able to
utilize and i know that some people are
doing that kind of stuff
so in sophisticated inference and this
is to bridge
the gap between the formalisms and the
actual sentences that are driving us
we're gonna kind of write it in a little
bit of a hybrid script
like a rebus so the big question that
agents are trying to answer
in the world and in sophisticated
inference is
how can we have the best policy over a
given time horizon
so not what's the best chess move now
it's what's the best chess move
over the time horizon that i'm
considering
and tied up in that question about
evaluating the best policy over a given
time horizon
is the question of what are the
consequences of policies through time
and how do we estimate that what is our
estimate
and what that is related to how we how
we benchmark
how we compare policies and their
consequences is specifically related to
how we understand observations being
mapped to hidden states
and our policy which is how our
actions are influencing the way that
hidden states change between each other
that's that b
matrix and the generalized free energy
which is this par
and fristen citation so another citation
link away from the i wide paper
is that the generalized free energy
basically consists of one model
that conditions on policies and then
asks about how state transitions occur
so
conditioning on me exercising every day
what kind of state transitions can i
expect to see in the world
and then the second part of the free
energy is conditioning on states
what policies should be selected so this
is the two-stroke engine
condition on what i know about the
world's world states and causal model of
the world generative model of the world
what is my policy selection that's the
control theory that's the cybernetic
side
that's the action side um action looking
side and then this first part is again
conditioning on my policies in the world
what are the state transitions and how
did those change and there's more nuance
because of course we're just describing
it in natural language but this is sort
of the broad
outline one half of free energy
conditions on policy
the other part um selects policy
and basically vice versa with state
transitions
and so here's related to this q and p
which we saw in tale of two densities
we talked about it again in integrating
internalism and externalism
q conditions on policy that's a vertical
line p
you're estimating o and s through t
through time
as conditioned on p and then
uh p is conditioned on states
so again we're conditioning on two
different parts
and uh that's also uh how we end up
using this two-stroke engine to do
inference in complex settings
we also talked about amortized inference
but don't want to go into that
here blue this is the slide that always
makes me
think about you with uh where's the
information gain
and could the pure information gaining
agent
get reward or does the pure reward
seeker gain information
and like where is this play interplay
between the intrinsic values or the
salience and then the intrinsic value in
the novelty
so the way that these two and all all
these different features and the
different representations i mean
there's so much to say about and think
here but stephen and then anyone else
yeah could you just go back to that the
one where you put those two terms
between action the generative
model and the that one yeah see
that's kind of interesting that
generative model says state transitions
policies
and policies final states so policies
final states is probably a bit more
action and like least
energy route and the other one maybe is
a bit more
generative models a bit more processed
and sensory
data it's a bit more cognitive
sort of feely cognition if that makes
sense i'd like that
that if that's correct but like is it
like that you've got like a perception
action part to those two in a way
one's a bit more perception heavy ones a
bit more action heavy or
let's return to that in a second blue
so i just wanted to comment while we're
here about like what you had said
in the um in the introduction video um
related to like why are we always trying
to you know
estimate the states when really we
should be trying to
estimate the best policy right like
that's what we should be
predicting over not trying to predict
the states like with this
bring three jackets instead of one
jacket and then you'll always be at the
right temperature
like if if we prepare versus trying to
predict
the the state of what's going to be i
think that that's a
just was a neat thought that occurred to
me exactly
um when there's too much emphasis on
precise
estimates of world states it's
implicitly like
we're focusing so much on precise
estimates of world states
that we'll just know what to do when we
have that precise estimate it's like
that's not true it turns out that maybe
again a one digit of precision or even
uh
to the nearest 10 of the temperature
from a policy perspective you'll be fine
if it's um 20 celsius plus or minus 10
you might be fine within a broad range
of world state predictions
from an action selection policy because
your action selection could be
cool i'll throw a jacket in my backpack
and then i'll be fine whatever it is
and so that is this um two-stroke engine
this hand-off or handshake between
co-estimating
states and their transitions like
weather in the world and the transitions
between different weather states in the
world
given what you know about weather we're
not on mars it's not going to do a you
know acid rain storm at 400 degrees
so it's like given what we know about
the distributions of the niche
the statistical regularities of the
niche we want to be
co-estimating states and
our action action and perception
and we want to be doing that in a way
that suffices
that's adequate to remain within our
preferred
areas our preferred strange attractors
where we're able to
basically have reduced uncertainty about
the things that we care about the
physiological variables that matter like
our temperature
and okay so it's it's is very
cool and again just for those who
haven't seen these kinds of equations
that much
the vertical line means conditions on
and then whatever follows it you can
think of is like fixed
so it's like you have a spreadsheet and
let's just say that the rows are
policies
and the columns are like state
transitions and so when you
fix on one it's like you pick out you
fix a column
and then you're asking about the
distribution of that vector
fixed on that column and similarly you
could fix
a row select one row condition on one
row
and then ask about the distribution in
that line
going across and so that's the full
matrix
and uh also that's related to what's
called marginal
likelihood in bayesian statistics the
margin is
literally the margin of the page when
they used to do it with physical pages
so it's like rows by columns and the
marginal likelihood
is related to the margin of the page
which is just so fun
it's kind of like a floppy disk icon but
for statistics
um here's another cool
piece of the sophisticated inference
paper
and i think there's a lot i'd like to
learn and ask here
to casper and others
but this formulation of
policy p pi selection can people people
can see my red thing right
pi is related to the argument
minimization
of free energy of policy so this is
saying
the policy that gets selected pi is
going to be like a free energy
minimization
of g as a function of all the policies
that could be done so of my affordances
we're going to do a free energy
minimization and that's how i'm going to
select my policy
okay well what is g of pi g of pi
is related to the expectation of
what risk minus ambiguity
so high risk is going to be a higher
number
and that's worse in this case we want
it's like golf
we want to minimize the free energy and
so we're
jointly trading off and there's some
natural logs and some negative natural
logs so
it's sometimes a little bit hard to see
if you're going like up or downhill
which is why it's so important to have
it phrased like this
but basically risk is bad and ambiguity
is bad but it turns out with the natural
logs that
you can just think of them as being
combined so it's like
if we seek to maximize um our precision
minimize risk minimize ambiguity what
we'll be doing
is actually a strict bound on
the intrinsic value and the extrinsic
value
so this formulation of search
of information gain related to risk and
ambiguity
turns out to be strictly bounded by this
value-driven process so
worldview related to reward you see that
agents are reward seekers
and uncertainty is something they just
simply deal with or they figure out or
they
thrive despite in the active inference
perspective
agents are uncertainty reducers who
obtain rewards and if they don't they
die that's evolution
and so we're putting risk and
uncertainty first
and so instead of saying like well the
agent predicts
value and that ends up reducing its
uncertainty about the world
we're actually saying no it's a way more
tractable calculation
for the agent to be reducing its
uncertainty about
action again not just about states the
world but the agent is reducing its
uncertainty about action
through action it's performing optimal
foraging experimentation
in order to reduce its uncertainty about
best actions
and it turns out that that is going to
have a bound
it's always going to be converging
towards
this perfect trade-off between intrinsic
and extrinsic value
and special cases fall out of this
where certain variables are basically
fixed to zero so if you have no
prior at the beginning and you just
let it start kind of draw from your
first observations
you take those and you use that as your
first hyper prior that's like the
parametric empirical base and
in this case you end up recapitulating
several things from bayesian statistics
like optimal bayesian design
or just surprise and then similarly
if you set the ambiguity to zero so
like the case in active inference eight
where
the states were perfectly observable
like the pendulum and the mountain car
it wasn't like it was getting a noisy
estimate of where it was on the mountain
it knew
exactly where it was on the mountain and
in the case of of no ambiguity
about states again ambiguity is the the
p
distribution of observations given
states so that's like
given that it's daytime am i seeing
photons so if you have no ambiguity
about that then this term is zero
right which makes risk minimization
the imperative and that's why when you
get no ambiguity
you find that this whole framework
collapses into
risk control whereas if you had
risk collapse to zero like it's a no
risk
situation the only imperative would be
reduction of ambiguity
so now let's think about that in reward
land if you didn't have to seek value
it could be purely novelty-based search
whereas if the only imperative were to
obtain short-term value
you would not expect that kind of agent
to be engaged in a creative search
so it's sort of like each of these are
um phrasings whether risk
minus ambiguity or intrinsic minus
extrinsic value
you can see how either one of them could
be like
zeroed out and what that would do for
the other side
or you could imagine in realistic
situations
where they're sort of like tied up in a
specific way
so again you could imagine a no risk
scenario a no ambiguity scenario
no intrinsic or no extrinsic any of
these combinations
we'll do steven and then sasha
yeah this is really good the way you're
putting this together here
and explaining it i think also this
obviously these things sometimes they
become really clear when it's an extreme
case then you've got this blending
that's going on um you know it's not
fully any one of these
but i i think that no ambiguity piece is
is is a useful one to think about what
happens sometimes when um
well you could say i don't know if you'd
say trump but when in the politics when
something is
if people say these people are bad and
you know you often see that even at work
and it's a no-brainer
things are said to be a no-brainer then
suddenly everyone
the the the intrinsic value of trying to
explore other options
is can be collapsed in people and they
just go
with the extrinsic value of
gain because there's no there's
supposedly no ambiguity
and i think that that could be
interested in social
yep situation yep like we know exactly
how dangerous
this virus is there's no discussion
about what the risk minimizing policy is
oh wait a minute is there sasha
okay very leading questions um
in hearing this description just
really thinking about
using this to define play and
really seeing play as the combination of
factors that has
very low risk but
like high uh value of exploration
and so setting up things that
have low risk but high opportunities for
curiosity
that would be i guess for me fit into
the category of play
so that's that's a good way to think
about it and
and another fun part there is like when
value is the imperative it's difficult
to be exploratory and creative it's like
maslow's hierarchy of needs
but then when there can be the space
where you can actually engage in a
novelty or a curiosity guided search
kind of the prerequisite the enabling
feature of that is sufficiency at a
material level
so that isn't simply related to reward
we don't just give people reward kind of
dial up their dopamine and then they'll
be acting creatively
it's actually like we need to scaffold
the agent in the environment
in a way where it can reduce its risk
so that it can tolerate higher ambiguity
or reduce ambiguity so that we can
engage
with higher risk scenarios so sometimes
these
combinations of features even though
risk and ambiguity they're just english
words so really it is about the
formalism
but it helps us reimagine and
repartition and fluidly
move across partitionings for how to
think about these nuanced control
problems
sasha um
also it makes me think about how this is
commonly studied like in psychology
lab spaces and
yeah really thinking about like how
using this framework to figure out
what would make the participants what
state that would put them in
as well as how uh
they feel about the risk and ambiguity
of the situation that they're in
because depending on how you feel about
participating in research
that would change what state of
exploration
or curiosity you might be in and that
i don't know it just really makes me
rethink a lot of um
research in this field because it's
ignoring
or i guess excluding one of the key
variables of this process
yep and it makes me think about safe
spaces
but we could also say how risky is this
space that's sort of related to safety
those are like one over
each other you know risk equals one over
safety but also
how ambiguous is this space we want this
space to be
safe so not risky but we also want this
not ambiguous we want to be clear and
communicating about what this space is
however we don't want to make it so
unambiguous there's no room to play
so we want to have the optimal level of
ambiguity and risk that's controlled
novelty
that's pareto optimality that's free
energy minimization
that's living on the frontier between
performance
and innovation so that's where all these
models can take us
and that's why it reimagines the bottom
up versus top down
the explorer versus exploit the
maximization in the long term versus the
short term
those are all coming from from the
reward mentality
and when we think about the situated
agent reducing uncertainty
about action through action we have a
whole new set of ways to talk about
these questions
stephen you're then blue and
bring it back as well with this paper
and you know the way it talks about
temple depth and and is it it can also
combine with this giveaway to think
about what they call stages of readiness
because people sort of think oh you know
that could read this and like okay we've
made it safe i've said it safe i've told
everyone it's safe
well it might be you've told them it's
safe and you've demonstrated it safe and
the environment's been safe but it might
be five minutes it might be
three weeks of training before people
start to
bring that safety into the way that they
balance these different parameters you
know so
the way that there and it could be that
it crashes quite rapidly
positive or negatively um as we saw
earlier with the
the way that the uh the dynamics work
and that
that's quite um that shows that
the importance of facilitation and the
importance of
the way the space is set up the safety
between participants and all that sort
of stuff
cool blue so i know that you said like
we're not going to unpack the formalism
of the
intrinsic value and the extrinsic value
or at least you said that on the intro
video
but um those two things like it makes me
think the special cases really like
you know they talked about no intrinsic
value but what about like
no extrinsic value like it just always
reminds me of like what about just
exploring for
you know info gain or um you know just
out of curiosity to satisfy that like
for intrinsic value
i did note that i was like waiting for
us like okay
no risk no ambiguity um then no
intrinsic it's like the next one
and uh i wondered if that actually was
related to
maximum entropy so it's like given a
distribution if you have
no preferences for value then you're
just
sampling your preference is to sample
the distribution
unadulterated and so that is like max
info game max ant sampling
neutrally without preference across a
distribution
and so that's very related to
statistical sampling techniques
because those computer algorithms have
been designed
actually without a preference vector in
mind just to sample
distributions like monte carlo markov
chain methods
and so now we're taking a sampling agent
you're sampling temperatures
but you don't want just all temperatures
for that distribution you want to sample
repeatedly from body temperature
however there might be another
distribution where you do want to have
a very very exploratory sampling pattern
let's just see if there's any other
interesting stuff so here is from
sophisticated inference
uh another kind of roll out and then
here we can see observations
and then there's different actions that
can be taken and each of those actions
would lead to different observations
and so on and so it gets exponentially
large and this is just like early chess
algorithms they used to do
if this then that if this then that and
they would do these rollouts and then
they'd prune this branch oh that doesn't
look that good so i'm not going to
explore that way
and since those sort of tree pruning
chess algorithms there's been
many developments in chess and other
algorithms for this kind of decision
making
and so here's the structure of the model
and here's that rollout and then one big
question is
how can we look down the branches that
are most informative
not just fantasize and dream about the
one in a billion branches that's the
best
not negatively ruminate and get dwelling
on the one branch that's the worst but
how can we sample
information across this branching tree
pattern
in a way that leads to effective action
in the world and then
here's another integrative plot that
they made which is showing that
basically
there's a few ways to think about active
inference what it's doing here
it's minimizing risk and minimizing
ambiguity okay
so that's related to this phrasing on
the top
minimize risk minimize ambiguity okay
make it safe
make it clear positive way of saying it
the negative way is minimize risk
minimize ambiguity
so policies states observations states
are the hidden part of the world
observations you know photons on my
retina policies where my eyes move
and so the risk framing is
you should be minimizing free energy in
a way that reduces risk and ambiguity
about this chain that connects policy
states and outcomes
another branch of active inference is
actually sort of like a yin and yang
this is like a push pull
it's saying minimize the entropy of the
distribution of
outcomes so achieve predictable
outcomes reduce big reduction on there
and expands here with the information
gain
and so instead of hey do something
that's like creative but
fyi don't be risky and don't be
ambiguous
here is like be as clear as you can and
predictable as you can the outcomes
while being as info gain and creative as
you possibly can
and so i like this because it's sort of
like instead of two things that you want
to run away from
and then hopefully you become creative
in the gap this is like
something to run away from and something
to run towards
so it rephrases that risk and ambiguity
minimization
as actually a push pull of a
minimization of surprise about
observations
and a maximization of the information
gain given
the um policies that can be carried out
so i kind of like that
graphic and then um just in those last
couple minutes um
casper and several other authors will be
on in early april hopefully before then
as well
for active 19 and that will be pretty
cool
but here's where they walk step by step
m1
at each time step the agent is inferring
how hidden states are related to
outcomes
then we see that s a o mapping
and now we have this and d is the
initial states now we're going to take
this single time point model
and use b to ask how states change their
time
then we're going to take m 2 that states
changing through time
and put it within a bigger model of m3
which is action
so policy is influencing how states
change their time the b matrix
policy is being selected by what
minimization of free energy
g how do we calculate minimized free
energy including a preference vector
c and then we have a prior over policies
this is related to the affordances
so now we're not just doing state
prediction at a moment but through time
m1 and m2 and we're going to be doing
policy selection
on that right now and then where we got
to
in sophisticated affective inference was
this m4
layer which is state observation
mappings through time
or at a given moment and through time
with a and the b
and choosing policy using our c
preference vector
and g the minimizing of free energy and
about that free energy
we're going to have a precision we're
going to have a prior
on our precision this is our
metacognition and here's where valence
enters the picture
which is anxiety bad anxiety comes from
high uncertainty so if you have high
precision
on free energy you're going to feel
better if you have low uncertainty or
low certainty
about free energy it's going to lead to
anxiety not because the expected value
of the outcomes is negative
so not within that reward first mindset
but in the precision first mindset even
a positive expected value with a high
variance can be anxiety producing
so we kind of return to the paper
as being the summation of these two
citations building
before just like so many other papers
are building on citations it's always
just like tips of icebergs all the way
down markov citation blankets all the
way down
and we can ask our kind of usual sets of
questions
and people can provide their closing
thoughts or questions or
what would they like addressed in 11.2
next week just what's something
fun that anyone or each of you thought
about today
and then also to kind of maybe even
close on a note
about how we can have accessible
formalisms for active inference and
include people in the discussion who
speak math or not
who speak english or not so how do we
communicate it make it exciting build
those bridges to other areas
any closing thoughts on that
stephen lots of really good stuff
i mean i suppose there's some elements
of this
where i'd love to find a way i'm trying
to find a way to take people into
an activity where you know
i suppose some of us do that you know
with play or with
an exploration different types of
exploration activities that maybe
illustrate some of these
and then they get unpacked after um
because it may be just some of this
stuff is in its nature pretty
involved but they're still good
um so i like the way you've been
describing it but maybe there's
maybe there's something then that this
now bridges with something else that's
experiential
cool anyone else have a thought on that
yeah i think that the questions i would
like to have the authors or anyone
familiar with the formalism
help us on would be how can we
um communicate and understand the
differences between partitioning
risk and ambiguity this way or that way
how do we know what to apply in what
scenario
how does it change how we act how does
it change how we model
systems how would we infer it in a
system
how do we disconnect the qualia
the experience of surprise uncertainty
ambiguity risk
valence how do we disconnect from the
qualia
so that we can apply it to systems that
are um on the other side of our markov
blanket systems that are we are not
experiencing but are acting in a way
uh in an intentional stance way they're
acting as if they had these kinds of
attributes
well um if there's any other thoughts we
can definitely
hear it but otherwise very excellent
discussion wait stephen do you have
another point
oh so everyone thanks for the awesome
discussion
there's a uh feedback form in the
calendar invite if you'd like to take a
look and fill that out
otherwise people who are watching it
live and in replay thanks so much
means a lot to us and we hope to hear
your questions
hear your thoughts so that we can
address them in 11.2
and thanks so much for a great 2020. we
are almost there this is the penultimate
active stream
so everyone thanks so much and we'll
talk later